valorant has a curse and it's real
and it's going to be 9-3
whoever you are however you play pro or
casual it'll strike you all the same
right oh my god
this is so stupid
a 9 3 lead for paper x lauren they can't
do it all is now benkai called upon
trying to save his side a great war bang
but six hp and two more to go vision
strikers have done enough
they call it the 9-3 curse teams up nine
to three at the half somehow always
manage to lose the game despite their
incredible lead that score is going to
creep up on you and it does it does seem
kind of like a curse but we're here to
tell you that it's more than just teams
coincidentally throwing on mass the 9-3
curse
is real i don't want to believe it i
really don't it just shouldn't be a
thing either it just shouldn't be a
thing but why speakers but it happens
every time
valorent is home to a strange
competitive curse
no one really knows how it started or
who the first person to be cursed was
but pretty quickly everybody started
noticing something weird
if you were up 9-3 at the half
you were almost guaranteed to lose
9-3 curse man i'm telling you the 9-3
curse is dangerous
sometimes it's better
it's better to lose the round and make
it 8-4
than half the 9-3 curse i'm telling you
now superstitions aren't new to esports
in fact we already have a few big ones
taught to get bodied don't kill the
chickens and of course bogdan's law
and actually that last one is really
important for understanding how the 93
curse works see bogdan's law is a cs go
superstition that holds that any player
with low hp has to swap out their rifle
for the op phelps is going to want to
push once more tag through the wall one
hp but they can't find the follow up and
he'll get away a nade would have done it
only one nade though and it's me that
has it so it was nearby they'll rotate
around give the op to the low hp player
i know that seems crazy because why he's
got such low hp why would you give a
valuable gun because he only needs to
hold an angle but somewhere along the
line people stopped treating it like a
tactic and started treating it like a
superstition if you don't respect
bogdan's law
you might regret it
i'm things fans holy [ __ ] i like that
bug then bugged in one hp bugged them
plugged in
like then bug then any bugs any bugs any
dance any bug dance
i like bug
what's bog damn bug then law steel's
lost law
bro do something please
die if you die
just don't give them something to shoot
at you don't stand behind a box with
what help you do that before all three
of us and just like bogdan's law the 9-3
curse is rooted in reality it might not
be a curse but teams are definitely
choking 9-3 leads over and over
oh my god oh my god he's been hit by
everything every piece of utilities just
landed at f speed and still envy walk
out with a double a triple a quadruple
opening almost the ace for marv to close
this round he was stunned up and
everything tom
nine rounds for envy incredible half oh
they're gonna eliminate sushi boy to
start with but patty is still going
strong on the back side down through the
cloud first it comes to bladestorm but
it's not even needed scary closes it out
and sca are going all the way to
playoffs when looking at the three land
events on the 2021 valor and champions
tour teams blew a 9-3 lead on five
separate occasions twice at stage 3
masters when paper rex and gambit both
[ __ ] the bed
they can't do it all is now benkai
called upon try and save his side a
great war bang but six hp and two more
to go vision strikers have done enough
attackers
came down to the wire
and then three more times at champions
when envy team vikings and ascend all
proved the 9-3 curse was legit they
ain't over yet cena and kill are still
here he's just seen everything he's
doing he descended in he gets red guard
but defoe
deals with kiles and it's going to be
9-3
good luck
because we know who's there red girl
this time holds across cena finds one
red guard sprays in he gets one
connection but it's still gonna be nuts
who finally gets denied by starzo
there's a two odds and it gets ripped
away red car it's ten seconds it's over
thirteen to eleven the nightmare
resurfaces for ascend and gambit
what's a turnaround and if that's not
enough to convince you that the 93 curse
is real let's take a look at the first
strike events from 2020. from na all the
way to indonesia the 93 curse struck at
least eight separate times and that's
only counting the playoff brackets if we
took a look at all
1707 matches there would probably be a
lot more cases
just think about all the possible score
lines and valorent all the potential
combinations
and yet teams keep hitting 9-3
and they keep losing right after
okay so i think at first like the knight
request was actually a thing and i think
it's like more in pro matches because
usually what happens is like the least
experienced team starts winning and then
like the more experienced team comes
back from an i3 or like they're losing
three time they come back
uh usually that happens because the more
experienced team just like they know how
to close it out and like that's
definitely the hardest part of the game
and now in like in ranked i think it's
just a meme like
that it's obviously not a real thing
of course like a lot of things in
esports the 9-3 curse feels like kind of
a meme at this point most of the war is
being made by streamers
and yet they are getting hit by it too
93 curse is real
i'm actually so salty in this game
so yeah it happens to pros streamers and
even casuals the 93 curse is absolutely
real
but what's causing it
well for starters you can blame the game
itself valrant is still pretty new so
the maps aren't completely balanced and
just like cs go momentum swings are a
huge part of the game
you can get that rug pulled out from
underneath you because all it takes
remember is to win is to lose one pistol
one bonus and then one gun round and
then they're tied then they're tied
because the other three rounds are ecos
that you usually don't win
but confidence is the key to victory in
any game it's obvious why the winning
teams keep completing these 9-3
comebacks the real question is why do
the losing teams keep blowing these
decisive leads over and over again
why do teams keep choking
well for as long as esports has been
around players and teams have thrown
away leads in pretty much any way you
can think of stewie's on his phone but
look at the time look at the time
there's seven seconds
they're trying to build pyramids but
it's no more crying
[Applause]
oh
and that could be the tournament point
puck goes on your invitational champion
over phenom
what a set puck comes back from losers
wow the drop of the century
down on white stairs waiting for the
vault on in is canadian will he be able
to secure the kill he sees the tracers
go no scyther will win the fight there's
geo just waiting he doesn't pull the
trigger he sees it he pops up oh no geo
you gotta hit your shots young will be
the last one left he was so important
for faze he turns his back he's got the
pistol but shepard will deny the
comeback from eg inches away
but they fumble it choking happens all
the time in esports and no one can
really agree on why the best players in
the world keep bottling it on the big
stage which is why orgs have been
working with sports psychologists for
years to try to avoid chokes before they
even happen however not everyone has
access to a sports psychologist for most
players the closest thing you're going
to get to mental health support is
logging off
so what is it that leads to this
collapse in confidence we asked madison
karkowski a computer science professor
at the university of saskatchewan who
specializes in computer human
interaction to get a better
understanding we recently have been
publishing on choking in in high
performance play um and what we found in
a recent uh study was that there was an
association between tendency to choke
and tendency to reinvest and what
reinvestment describes is a switch from
um procedural which is fast automatic
processing and thinking to a more slow
declarative step-by-step thinking which
is much more explicit to put it simply
what madison is talking about is doubt
and overthinking choking is a slippery
slope and once we fall down that rabbit
hole we continue to lose confidence in
our abilities think about it you lose
one round and that immediately makes you
doubt your ability to win the next and
then the next and then the next and then
the other team is taking control of the
game
and it only gets worse if you already
know about the 9-3 curse because then
it's easier for your brain to play
tricks on you so it could be what's
happening as people are seeing you know
they've ended the half at 9-3 and now
they're worried that they're going to
choke they're worried that they're going
to throw the game
which you know makes them doubt their
own performance which makes it a high
pressure situation which means that
people who are likely to reinvest might
reinvest and then they're going to like
have that slower more declarative
thinking which negatively impacts
performance
so it could be that the 9-3 curse is
real but it's really only people's
knowledge of the curse that makes it a
curse and it's kind of self-inflicted
we're probably never going to have a
definitive explanation for why the 9-3
curse happened there are a lot of
factors that go into something like that
but hopefully now you understand how
so-called curses like this are born and
the 9-3 curse might actually be good for
the game
the fact that teams can mount incredible
comebacks like this makes valorant all
the more exciting to watch and nitro
coming in with a fan or a specter can
they make it happen chronicle yeah he's
gonna get cleaned up you asked if they
could make it happen they can nitro gets
the last one so for for gambit they get
a 9-3 half shade off's good for wine
trades one doubt oh just narrowly not
able to get the second
chronicle
has plenty of health chronicle on the
tap
he's got it rose don't fake he's got to
get it to happen
he gets four he gets the red bull clutch
100 thieves were down but they steal the
round away from gambit to push us to map
three 11 straight rounds coming from 100
thieves perseverance and experience
of course it's a lot less exciting if
you're on the receiving end of the curse
but there is hope if you stay calm play
comfortably and reclaim that confidence
that won you those first nine rounds
then eventually with a little bit of
practice and conditioning you can beat
those tricks we all play in ourselves
the 9-3 curse might be real but every
curse can be defeated
however not everyone has access to a
sports psychologist for most players the
closest thing you're going to get to
mental health support is logging off
honestly logging off is the ultimate
mental support the best thing you can do
for yourself is log off
are you online that's your problem